gelandet im zentrum der macht war donald
trump als außenseiter jetzt will er das
weiße haus verteidigen wie hat trump
sein land und amerikas rolle in der welt
bisher verändert wie bekommen die
menschen seine politik zu spüren
[Musik]
und was ist noch von diesem präsidenten
zu erwarten dessen verlässlichste
eigenschaft seine unberechenbarkeit ist
[Musik]
der kampf ums weiße haus ist in vollem
gange am dritten november hat amerika
die wahl ob donald trump ihr wohnen
bleibt oder ob jemand anderes einziehen
darf hier in washington sieht die große
mehrheit trump eher kritisch aber
jenseits von washington lieben viele
menschen trump für seine kantigen worte
und für sein versprechen amerika wieder
großartig zu machen
der countdown läuft die
präsidentschaftswahl steht bevor und sie
alle hier in dallas texas wollen donald
trump helfen das weiße haus zu
verteidigen das amtsenthebungsverfahren
hat trump mit einem freispruch
überstanden und hier stellten sie sich
schon vorher hinter ihren präsidenten
ich denke nicht dass er etwas falsches
getan hat ich sage nicht dass er ein
perfekter mann ist aber eine
amtsenthebungsverfahren ist nicht
gerechtfertigt er hat für uns alles
getan was er konnte und dieses verfahren
ist nur ein schwindel der demokraten
weil sie angst vor ihm haben
rund 20.000 menschen warten teilweise
stundenlang vor der arena um trump
sprechen zu hören
normalerweise treten hier rockstars auf
[Musik]
die amerikanische nationalhymne wird zur
einstimmung auf die rede des präsidenten
gesungen
[Musik]
und trump stimmt einen medley seiner
wahlkampfthemen an mit denen er schon
2016 erfolg hatte
[Musik]
wir bauen eine großartige mauer entlang
der südlichen grenze
und sie wächst schnell in die höhe v die
mauer skandieren die texanischen fans
des präsidenten dass trumps ein
wahlkampfversprechen nur teilweise
erfüllen konnte und bislang vor allem
bestehende grenzanlagen ausbauen lassen
hat nimmt ihn hier niemand übel denn
schuld daran seien die demokraten
sie haben die finanzierung gestoppt sie
haben den bau fast unmöglich gemacht
aber wir haben uns ein bisschen geld von
hier ein bisschen geld von dort und dann
von überall besorgt und jetzt bauen wir
das ding 2500 kilometer weiter westlich
los angeles im liberalen kalifornien
wirkt wie eine andere politische welt
draußen vor den toren der stadt lebt der
schriftsteller tc boyle schon vor 25
jahren schrieb er in seinem roman
amerika über wohlhabende us bürger die
aus angst vor mexikanischen einwanderern
eine mauer errichten und sich
radikalisieren
wie hat er das kommen sehen
wir sind eine spezies wir sollten alle
miteinander auskommen so gut wir können
ohne diese vorurteile aber in der
tradition des faschismus findet man
immer einen sündenbock und das ist oft
der fremde
das ist was wir erleben es ist eine
furchtbare schande für amerika und für
die amerikanische geschichte roms
präsidentschafts wirke sich nicht nur
auf das gesellschaftliche klima aus
sondern auch auf die umwelt meint tief
denn trump habe zahlreiche umweltschutz
gesetze abgeschafft mit langfristigen
folgen
ich glaube wir sind dabei uns auf die
letzten epochen der menschheit
zuzubewegen davor zu kollabieren
wir sind schon jetzt 7,3 milliarden
menschen und der klimawandel wird sich
negativ auf die essens ressourcen
ausland und natürlich erhöht sich schon
jetzt der meeresspiegel
wenn du dachtest die syrische
flüchtlingskrise war schrecklich warte
bis die fluten in bangladesch 60
zentimeter hoch sind wo werden all die
menschen hingehen
ganz in der nähe von tc boyles haus
zeigen sich andere auswirkungen des
klimawandels schon jetzt hier in
kalifornien wüten wegen heftiger dürren
immer wieder wald brennt forscher
rechnen damit dass solche katastrophen
aufgrund der erderwärmung häufiger
auftreten von solchen zusammenhängen
wollen trumps anhänger in texas nichts
wissen dass der präsident den austritt
aus dem pariser klimaabkommen erklärt
hat wird hier gefeiert
das ganze klima geredet doch ein haufen
bullen mist ich glaube es einfach nicht
die haben noch keine echten
wissenschaftlichen fakten
ich bin zwar kein experte für klima aber
ich stehe einfach hinter dem was trump
in der sache tot
der präsident selbst verkauft so einen
kampf gegen den umweltschutz als eine
der größten leistungen seiner amtszeit
wir haben eine rekordzahl an umwelt
regulierungen beseitigt die usa sind
jetzt die nummer eins unter den öl und
erdgasproduzenten weltweit
doch jeder der demokratischen
präsidentschaftskandidaten will die öl
und gasproduktion abschaffen
ich glaube die wollen zu windrädern
zurückkehren
eine botschaft die ankommt seine
wirtschaftspolitik ist großartig an der
börse läuft es super
ich persönlich arbeite in einem casino
und das boomt man spürt dass die leute
plötzlich mehr zum ausgeben haben
fakt ist während trumps präsidentschaft
ist die arbeitslosigkeit auf den
niedrigsten stand seit 50 jahren
gesungen der amerikanische aktienindex
dow jones kletterte zwischenzeitlich auf
ein rekordhoch
dies gelang auch weil trump die
unternehmenssteuer maßgeblich senkte
wegen der florierenden wirtschaft hat
trump wohl gute chancen wiedergewählt zu
werden sie das auch so ein prominenter
kritiker tc boyle so in zeiten einer
starken wirtschaft wird traditionell der
amtsinhaber wiedergewählt
dennoch denke ich dass dies eine
spezielle situation ist in der die
demokratie in gefahr ist
ich hoffe dass genügend wechselwähler
erkennen werden wie falsch es ist diesen
mann im weißen haus zu halten
bald muss amerika sich entscheiden ob es
weltoffen und umweltbewusstsein will wie
tc boyles kalifornien oder
nationalistisch und
unternehmerfreundlich wie trumps texas
hinter mir liegt der eingang zum
westflügel des weißen hauses wo sich das
büro von präsident trump befindet zwei
wörter sind daraus immer wieder zu hören
america first amerika zuerst die usa
seien etwa beim welthandel
jahrzehntelang benachteiligt worden ist
trump überzeugt deshalb fordert er eine
grundlegende reform der
welthandelsorganisation wto
und er hat einstige handelspartner wie
mexiko kanada europa und china mit
sonderzahlung überzogen um bessere
abkommen zu erreichen
deals wie transnet doch durch diese
strategie gerät trump im wahljahr auch
unter druck denn viele seiner wähler
bekommen die gegen celle heftig zu
spüren zum beispiel landwirte und
fischer
[Musik]
bekannt ist der bundesstaat im nordosten
der usa für seine felsküste und seinen
indian summer die wärmephase im herbst
wenn sich die blätter verfärben und
viele touristen anziehen
dieses anwesend war der alterssitz des
früheren präsidenten george bush senior
er war ein überzeugter verfechter des
freihandels nun wird ausgerechnet maine
zum schauplatz eines handels konfliktes
zwischen den usa und china
die fischer in maine leiden unter
chinesischen sonderzone auf
amerikanische hunger die exporte nach
china sind um 80 prozent eingebrochen
das spürt auch michael lieber guter
geschäfte mit china haben direkt dorthin
geliefert
dann kamen die zölle und jetzt kaufen
sie nicht bei uns sondern in kanada das
ist frustrierend
seit 44 jahren fängt michael hunger
schon mit 15 bewarb er sich erfolgreich
um eine fang lizenz dabei war ihm dieses
handwerk gar nicht in die wiege gelegt
worden
mein vater war ein relevanter mann er
hat mit george bush senior in jena
studiert und waren den uni harvard und
princeton
er wurde lehrer verdiente sehr gut aber
als ich 20 war verdiente ich in einem
monat schon mehr als er im ganzen jahr
also entschied ich mich fischer zu
bleiben
heute ist es nicht mehr so leicht aber
damals war es einfach hunger fang ist
handarbeit mit diesen brüdern sollen die
schalentiere in die falle gelockt werden
400 dieser körper haben michael und sein
mitarbeiter heute im einsatz um den
hunger bestand zu sichern ist die
fischerei in maine streng reguliert
michael muss die tiere messen
noch zu klein sind muss er in die
freiheit schenken
wir hatten kein glück die scheren werden
mit gummis zusammengebunden damit die
hunger sich empfang becken nicht
gegenseitig auffressen
die eu arbeitet seit einem jahr für
michael
auch er hat schon gemerkt was der
handelsstreit mit china für das geschäft
bedeutet das schadet unseren preis ohne
den handelskonflikt würden wir mehr
bekommen
ich kann nämlich nicht im detail damit
aus aber wir könnten etwas hilfe von der
regierung gebraucht
nicht nur die auseinandersetzung mit
china macht den fischern das leben
schwer sondern auch das klima so warm
wie an diesem herbsttag als über weite
strecken des sommers nicht
es regnete 4 das wasser ist deshalb
kälter als gewöhnlich und wirkt sich
negativ auf den fang aus
[Musik]
immerhin rund 500 hummer bringen die
beiden heute in den hafen von portland
der chef persönlich schafft die
wertvolle ladung an land ein teil des
fangs landet bei diesem zwischenhändler
hier werden die tiere für den
weitertransport verpackt
und 5,5 millionen kilogramm hunger
fleisch exportierten die usa 2018 nach
china im vergangenen jahr war es nur
noch eine million kilo für unternehmer
tom adams eine hiobsbotschaft ängste bei
mir persönlich bei unseren angestellten
in der ganzen industrie
diese ängste sind auch immer noch da
denn wir brauchen den zugang zu allen
internationalen märkten es ist eine
große industrie und ein großes geschäft
für mails von einem großen markt
abgeschlossen zu sein macht es schwer
für unser unternehmen zu wachsen
90 prozent seines china geschäftes haben
kanadische wettbewerber übernommen um
die einbrechenden exporte nach china zu
kompensieren musste man neue märkte
erschließen inzwischen werden die hummer
hier auch in andere asiatische länder
wie singapur taiwan und malaysia
verkauft obwohl amerikas handelsstreit
mit china dem unternehmen schadet bringt
der chef teilweise verständnis für die
politik von präsident trump auf
everybody fast jeder außerhalb chinas
betrachtet die art und weise wie china
handel betrieben hat als unfair aber es
hat wohl auch politische gründe dass der
handelskonflikt andauert und zeitweise
eskaliert während die auseinandersetzung
zwischen den usa und china weiter geht
versucht michael möglichst viele seiner
oma direkt an lokale restaurants in
maine zu verkaufen
im dampfgarer wird die delikatesse
zubereitet und im ganzen mit beilage
serviert
im angebot gibt es zwei für umgerechnet
23 euro
wer nicht selbst die schale knacken will
bestellt das hühnerfleisch mit
mayonnaise im brötchen
michael bekommt hierfür seine hunger
weniger als früher
doch immerhin das feierabendbier geht
aufs haus
auch sein kumpel toll es ist unternehmer
betreibt eine algenfarm wer wird
gewinnen wenn man den handelskonflikt
mit china wie ein schachspiel betrachtet
einen gewinner geben es ist lächerlich
eine seite hat immer nur kurzfristig
einen vorteil doch dafür steht zu viel
auf dem spiel es ist nicht schwarz oder
weiß wer wird aus michael sicht gewinnen
wahrscheinlich die chinesen
ich habe kein vertrauen in unseren
präsidenten ist irgendwie ein clown zu
schacht figuren der weltpolitik sind die
roma fischer in maine geworden im großen
spiel der mächte usa und china bekommen
sie hier manchen zug zu spüren
bertrams politik noch zu spüren bekommt
und wie er das land bisher verändert hat
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit jemandem
der selbst im weißen haus gearbeitet hat
pedro war außenpolitischer berater von
präsident george hw bush heute ist dafür
dass hudson institute tätig das ist ein
think tank der den republikanern nahe
steht peter ist sohn eines amerikaners
und einer österreicherin und deshalb
sprechen wir deutsch miteinander peter
präsident trump hat versucht alle
möglichen handelsabkommen aufzukündigen
neu aufzulegen bessere deals zu
erreichen wie er es nennt wie
erfolgreich ist er damit bisher ist eine
gemischte bilanz also erst mit sehr viel
diskussion gestartet hat eine reihe von
neuen verhandlungen angekündigt
teilweise ist dies geglückt mit kanada
und mexiko hat einen neuen deal
ausgehandelt mit der chinesin einen teil
die leine verloren die man hier
den usa sagt und andere große
verhandlungen mit europäern stehen ihnen
noch zuvor da braucht er möglicherweise
noch eine zweite amtszeit wäre es ihnen
wirklich gelingen wird wir haben vorhin
im beitrag gesehen dass viele fischer
teilweise das zu spüren bekommen auch
diese handelskonflikte honorieren die
wähler das trotzdem das versucht für
amerika mehr herauszuholen oder ist er
der schaden für ihn groß weil man die
auswirkungen spürt ich glaube dass man
mehr akzeptanz hat für diese neue
weltordnung wo es wettbewerb und
neuverhandlungen immer mehr ins geschäft
kommt wo die usa vielleicht eine neue
liberale weltordnung und
handelsbeziehungen anstrebt aber er muss
resultate er muss letztendlich in den
wirtschaftsdaten etwas aufzeigen können
bis jetzt läuft die amerikanische
wirtschaft sei gut darauf setzt personen
trump sie haben gerade die gute
wirtschaftslage angesprochen die
arbeitslosigkeit ist sehr niedrig die
börse ist teilweise auf rekordhoch aber
das ganze scheint teuer erkauft zu sein
denn die staatsverschuldung explodiert
ist das im moment einen wirtschaftsboom
auf kosten der nächsten generation
ja da gibt es vielleicht jetzt einen
überparteilichen konsens zwischen den
republikanern und demokraten dass man
dies jetzt nicht angeht die
schuldenquote liegt bei 104 105 prozent
des bruttoinlandsprodukts das ist noch
schlug das ist noch verdaubar aber
mittel und langfristig mal ganz klein
müssen hier reformen starten und das
dagegen unternehmen
kurzfristig steht hier aber nicht in
aussicht die demokraten würden sich die
gegen bayern-präsident rampe das auch
nicht dass priorität angekündigt das
bedeutet dass im pietschmann verfahren
für den wahlkampf von präsident trump
ich glaube eigentlich relativ wenig es
ist von vielen amerikanern als
politische schlammschlacht wahrgenommen
es ist ein hoch wichtiges thema es ist
eine verfassungskrise könnte man
wahrhaftig sagen aber letztendlich
glaube ich wird es bedeutungslos sein
was dem ausgang angeht trump polarisiert
wie kaum ein präsident vor ihm er
spaltet lieber als das versöhnt reicht
es nur auf seine eigene weller basis zu
setzen um wiedergewählt zu werden
schwer zu sagen 2016 hat das gereicht
gegen hillary clinton da war der gleiche
präsident wie er es heute ist oder der
kandidat wie er heute als präsident
auftritt 2018 aber bei der kongresswahl
haben die republikaner wirklich herbe
verluste einstecken müssen in den
vorstädten wo die gemäßigt der
mittelschicht damals shampoo die
amerikanische parteilos abgelehnt
das heißt es hat 2016 2018 echt nicht
2020 steht offen
sie selbst haben für andere publikum
präsidenten gearbeitet wie zufrieden
sind sie persönlich denn mit der
präsidentschaft donald trumps bisher
gute frage ja so teilweise die inhalte
der regierung und das gesamtkonzept
republikaner also die mehrheit im senat
und die administration selbst die würde
ich durchaus als gut beurteilen die
körperschaftssteuer senkung die
ernennung und dann auch bestätigung von
konservativen richtern die vom
präsidenten ernannt werden und dann
funktional bestätigt das finde ich alles
gut und positiv fielen mir wünschen dass
er da noch schauen vielleicht etwas
anders mit unseren bündnispartnern
umgehen würde insbesondere die
bundeskanzlerin aber wir haben über über
jahre auch bestimmte anliegen immer
wieder veröffentlicht auch in der bush
regierung die würden nicht immer glaube
ich so ernst genommen und jetzt ist halt
ein anderer stil da also teilweise
positiv im stil vielleicht nicht immer
so über den umgang mit den
bündnispartnern und die außenpolitik von
präsident trump sprechen wir nachher
noch einmal peter jetzt gehen wir
erstmal darunter und machen eine
kaffeepause
denn als journalist muss man bei diesen
präsidenten nicht nur wach sondern auch
wachsam sein
das weiße haus im west wing dem
westflügel hat nicht nur donald trump
sein büro sondern auch einige
journalisten die permanent über den
präsidenten berichten die größten
amerikanischen zeitungen radio und
fernsehsender haben hier eigene
arbeitsplätze eingerichtet
im sogenannten tress briefing room
finden pressekonferenzen statt
hier in diesem saal befand sich früher
ein schwimmbad dass präsident roosevelt
sich hatte einbauen lassen aber als
immer mehr journalisten ins weiße haus
drängten da dies präsident nixon den
stöpsel ziehen und funktionierte den
pool zum briefing room um hier ist alles
ziemlich beengt deshalb gibt es auch
keine kantine für die journalisten
sondern nur einen kleinen pausenraum
aber dafür immerhin steht hier im weißen
haus die kaffeemaschine des
schauspielers tom hanks aber wie kommt
die ins weiße haus
jeff mason muss es wissen er berichtet
seit 10 jahren für die
nachrichtenagentur reuters aus dem
weißen haus und war sogar präsident der
white house correspondents association
also der vereinigung der journalisten
die im weißen haus akkreditiert sind
einmal ist tom hanks zu uns gekommen hat
uns gesucht weiß nicht warum er im
weißen haus war es auf jeden fall zu
unserer arbeitsplatz hierher gekommen
hat gesehen dass wir irgendwie keine
gute karten gehabt haben und dann hat er
uns geschenkt und wollte dafür auch
seine unterstützung für die
pressefreiheit sei krebskrank hingegen
beschimpft kritische journalisten als
feinde des amerikanischen volkes
auch jeff mason wurde schon zum ziel
solcher attacken als der tramp auf die
ukraine affäre ansprach reagierte der
aggressiv das ganze ist ein schwindel
und wissen sie wer dazu beiträgt leute
wie sie und die lügen presse in vielen
fällen spreche ich auch von den
korrupten medien denn sie sind korrupt
nicht nur der ton gegenüber journalisten
habe sich im vergleich zu früheren
präsidenten geändert berichtet mason
es hat sich es hat sich auch geändert
apropos tracking dass man
immer wieder schauen und checken muss
dass das was er gesagt hat ob es richtig
ist oder nicht ist es ja eigentlich
immer unsere aufgabe ist journalistin
das zu machen aber bei präsident schauen
müssen wir das öfter machen
fakt ist seit seinem amtsantritt hat
trump laut washington post mehr als
16.000 falsche oder irreführende
aussagen gemacht da muss man als
berichterstatter hellwach sein um die
fakten zu überprüfen
in diesem sinne erklärt tom hanks ein
geschenk an die journalisten
schweine kaffee braucht der
kaffeemaschine hat tom hanks eine karte
beigelegt und sein appell an uns
journalisten lautet kämpft weiter für
wahrheit gerechtigkeit und den
amerikanischen weg besonders für den
teil mit der wahrheit
auch präsidenten brauchen mal eine
auszeit präsident trump verbringt seine
freizeit am liebsten in seinem golf club
mar lago in florida sein vorgänger
abraham lincoln blieb lieber in der
nachbarschaft des weißen hauses und kam
hierher ins traditionsreiche hotel auch
präsident grant macht es sich hier gerne
mit einem drink gemütlich doch mit der
zeit lauerten ihm interessenvertreter
aus der wirtschaft in der lobby auf um
ihn für ihre zwecke zu beeinflussen
der begriff des lobbyisten war geboren
präsident trump hatte versprochen den
einfluss der lobbyisten zu begrenzen
er werde den sumpf washington
austrocknen so trump aber hat er seinen
worten auch taten folgen lassen
der summe so wird washington dc im
volksmund genannt
nicht nur weil teile von amerikas
hauptstadt tatsächlich auf sumpfgebiet
gebaut wurden viele bürger empfinden
washington auch als moralisch
vermoderten ort an dem das große geld
entscheidet wer hier für wen politik
macht mit dem versprechen diesen sumpf
auszutrocknen war donald trump im
präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2016
angetreten
[Musik]
wir werden den sumpf der korruption in
washington dc austrocknen
ob trump sein versprechen gehalten hat
kann mark bloomfield gut beurteilen
der sumpf ist sein geschäftsgebiet
bloomfield ist lobbyist in washington er
lebt davon politiker im sinne seiner
klienten zu beeinflussen
komponist dem kapitol oder in der
regierung finden der deine position
einnimmt und dann werden die gesetze von
uns geschrieben
allerdings müsse man dafür eine menge
geld mitbringen wenn du eine große
spende machst wirst du wahrscheinlich
den abgeordneten für ein foto treffen
eine wahlkampfspende erhöht also deine
zugangsmöglichkeiten und zugang führt zu
einfluss lied zugang führt so einfluss
[Musik]
bloomfield zeigt uns seinen zugang zur
macht auf den fluren des kapitols fühlt
er sich wie zu hause in das vorzimmer
des mehrheitsführers im senat spaziert
er ganz selbstverständlich hinein
der begriff lobbyist zwei schließlich
entstanden weil interessenvertreter wie
er oft in der lobby eines politikers
lauern wird
er soll für die senatoren interessant
weil er wahlkampfspenden vermitteln
könnte hält ist wichtig weil eine wahl
sehr teuer ist allein die kandidatur in
kalifornien für einen senatssitz hier
kann 100 millionen dollar kosten
die fernsehwerbespots und die
zielgruppen forschung sind kostspielig
geld ist wichtig weil es teuer ist
gewählt oder wiedergewählt zu werden die
kids expensive für die spender können
sich die investition in barer münze
auszahlen
manni das große geld kann kleine
entscheidungen beeinflussen
zum beispiel ob ein unternehmen eine
steuererleichterung bekommt oder ob ein
umweltgesetz geändert wird der kongress
ein ort an dem sich gesetz einfach
kaufen lassen
gegen diesen eindruck kämpft der
demokratische kongressabgeordnete eric
smallville der sich zwischenzeitlich um
die präsidentschaftskandidatur bewarb er
setzt sich für eine begrenzung von
wahlkampfspenden 1
denn die waffenlobby verhindere mit
ihren millionen eine verschärfung der
waffengesetze
trotz einer serie von amokläufen in den
usa
die nhl spendet für wahlkämpfe von
verschiedenen kongressabgeordneten und
das geld fließt in unbegrenzter höhe mit
hilfe von organisationen die nicht
offiziell zu den politikern gehören
schienen aber nahe steht
die waffenlobby muss nicht mal
veröffentlichen wie viel geld sie
spendet
forssell und seine demokraten fordern
mehr transparenz auch für die herkunft
von spendengeldern
sie haben im repräsentantenhaus ein
gesetz verabschiedet das sogenannte
stark money verhindern soll
mit diesem dunklen geld sind
millionenspenden an abgeordnete gemeint
die vor der öffentlichkeit geheim
gehalten werden
doch trumps republikaner blockieren das
verbot von darf man ihn mit ihrer
mehrheit im senat
die macht der mega spender scheint
unantastbar
er ist einer von ihnen zum star hat mit
einem hedgefonds milliarden verdient
allein im letzten
präsidentschaftswahlkampf spendete er
rund 100 millionen dollar an die
demokraten
jetzt kandidiert er selbst wer politisch
etwas erreichen wolle müsse nun einmal
tief in die tasche greifen
ich denke die demokratie ist korrupt sie
sind uns bewusst dass unser system so
ist deshalb versuche ich mit meinem geld
eine graswurzelbewegung zu organisieren
um bürger als wähler zu registrieren
aber dabei versuchen wir ganz
transparent zu sein so dass jeder sehen
kann was wir tun und warum die andere
seite tut das nicht
mit der anderen seite man ja trump und
die republikaner steuer investiert
gerade wieder viele millionen um mit
einer kampagne öffentlichkeit und
abgeordnete davon zu überzeugen dass der
präsident des amtes enthoben werden muss
denn trump sei korrupt großspender bei
demokraten und republikanern ist
washington unter trump ein sumpf
geblieben
china krumholz erforscht die effekte des
geldes auf die politik ihre daten zeigen
seit trumps amtsantritt eine eindeutige
tendenz
die ausgaben für lobbyismus gehen nur in
eine richtung nach oben
die zahl der lobbyisten ist gestiegen
trump hatte versprochen ihren einfluss
auf seine regierung zu begrenzen doch
davon ist nichts zu sehen
ziemlich das gegenteil ist der fall
tatsächlich habe trump sogar lobbyisten
zu regierungsmitgliedern ernannt das
prominenteste beispiel andrew wylie
kämpfte als lobbyist der kohleindustrie
gegen verordnungen der umweltbehörde
trump macht er ausgerechnet villa zum
chef der umweltbehörde
das center for responsive politics
listet 163 weitere lobbyisten auf die
jobs in der tramp regierung bekommen
haben und washington wird wohl auch nach
der präsidentschaftswahl 2020 einen
sumpf bleiben egal wer gewinnt
konzerne und interessengruppen sichern
sich ihren einfluss auf das weiße haus
schon jetzt wieder mit spenden 700.000
dieser geldbündel werden laut einer
studie in den wahlkampf fließen die
rekord summe von 7 milliarden dollar
wenn ich washington verlasse und draußen
im land unterwegs bin wirkt amerika auf
mich zerrissen zwischen arm und reich
zwischen stadt und landbevölkerung
zwischen schwarz und weiß präsident
trump scheint diese spaltung weiter
voranzutreiben so sehr dass mancher im
us bundesstaat kalifornien sich sogar
abspalten möchte vom rest der
vereinigten staaten hier in den hügeln
von hollywood setzen sie die revolution
im 10
jetzt fiel kalifornien soll auf den
vereinigten staaten austreten und
unabhängig werden die bürgerinitiative
independent california hat nach eigenen
angaben rund 30.000 mitglieder je länger
donald trump präsident ist desto mehr
werden ist alles was aus trumps mund
kommt dreht sich um muslime und latinos
doch er erwähnt nicht all diese
schießereien von weißen nationalisten
das ist die bedrohung nummer eins in
diesem land doch der präsident ignoriert
das und macht es sogar noch schlimmer
die zahl von weißen nationalisten steigt
aber nicht hier in kalifornien wir haben
dafür null toleranz er polarisiert trump
attackiert jedem werk ein wohlhabender
weißer mann ist das tut er sehr bewusst
diese politik wird kalifornien als bunt
gemischt es dem staat der usa nicht
gerecht regelmäßig trifft sich die
bürgerinitiative die mitglieder beraten
darüber wie sie eine volksabstimmung
über den auftritt kaliforniens auf den
usa erreichen können laut umfragen
spricht sich bereits jeder dritte bürger
für den sogenannten karl exit aus unsere
stimmen unsere sichtweisen unsere
belange werden auf der internationalen
bühne nie so sichtbar wie sie sollten
das ist eine schande denn wenn
kalifornien eine eigene unabhängige
außenpolitik hätte wären wir eine art
umweltfreundliche supermacht in dieser
hinsicht hätten wir viel mit deutschland
gemeinsam
eine art wirtschaftlicher macht ist der
sonnenschein staat schon jetzt gemessen
am bruttoinlandsprodukt ist kalifornien
die fünftgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
dementsprechend selbstbewusst regiert
man in der landeshauptstadt sacramento
in der umweltpolitik etwa geht
kalifornien eigene wege erklärt die vize
gouverneurin donald trump das land auf
den pariser klimaabkommen führen will
haben wir als bundesstaaten die
fähigkeit und wir hier in kalifornien
auch die verantwortung nicht nur im
abkommen zu bleiben sondern unsere
stimme auf der weltbühne zu erheben
die griechischstämmige linicus leistet
auch widerstand gegen trumps
einwanderungspolitik
sie schützt in kalifornien illegale
einwanderer vor der abschiebung
wenn wir die politik der tramp regierung
sehen und hören etwa das an der grenze
kinder von ihren eltern getrennt werden
dann verstört uns das sehr
deshalb heben wir unsere stimme und
handeln bei wichtigen themen wie
einwanderung und umwelt eine eigene
politik zu verfolgen sei besser als ein
austritt aus den vereinigten staaten
meinte vize gouverneurin die
bürgerinitiative independent california
ist da anderer meinung
das ist wirklich zur unabhängigkeit
kaliforniens kommt ist aktuell zwar
unwahrscheinlich doch sollte trump
wiedergewählt werden so denkt man hier
könnten die chancen für den calexico
steigen nicht nur in kalifornien lehnen
viele menschen trumps politik ab sondern
auch in anderen teilen der welt
laut einer umfrage empfindet die große
mehrheit der deutschen trump als größere
gefahr für den weltfrieden als kim jong
il oder putin die daraus sind diese
ängste berechtigt das tat schon pirat
ist würde ich gar nicht bestreiten das
ist sicherlich der fall aber ich glaube
es ist auch mit tieferen strukturellen
faktoren zu verstehen oder zu begründen
die usa hat ja eine andere
vorgehensweise manchmal sieht man aus
deutscher sicht vielleicht dialog als
gleichgestellt mit frieden aber die
amerikaner glauben dass man ab und zu
auch hier bestimmte maßnahmen ergreifen
muss dass es nicht deeskalation ist dass
freundschaft sondern ein dämon das
bedeutet eine strategie der apa
trump hat versucht die nukleare
bedrohung durch den iran und durch
nordkorea einzudämmen wie erfolgreich
ist ihm das bisher gelungen
das sind wirklich zwei unterschiedliche
fälle im fall von nordkorea muss man
sagen dass multilateral über die uno
mehrere sicherheitsabkommen
verabschieden hat können die neutrale
wirklich in bedrängnis bringen
wirtschaftlich insbesondere iran ist er
eine bilaterale sache wo die usa direkt
durch wirtschaftssanktionen auch wenn
ich der europäer nicht unterstützt haben
gegen den iran vorgeht das sind zwei
unterschiedliche amerikanische
strategien und ein zusatz gibt es im
falle von iran natürlich auch die
regionalen probleme die man in nordkorea
nicht so hatte nordkoreas umgeben von
starken staaten ihren schwachen sie
haben für george hw bush gearbeitet der
die kriege in afghanistan und im irak
begonnen hat trump hat wörtlich
versprochen diese endlosen kriege wie er
sagt zu beenden
nun hat er doch wieder die truppen
aufgestockt im nahen osten welches ziel
verfolgt er denn nun eigentlich
ich glaube das paradox ist dass man
durch truppen entsenden nicht unbedingt
krieg betreibt wir haben truppen
aufgestockt in europa nachdem wladimir
putin der ukraine angegriffen hat auch
georgien 2008 wir haben in südkorea in
der nähe von so große anzahl von
amerikanischen truppen stationiert wir
führen in europa sowie auch in nordost
asien keinen krieg das heißt man kann
vielleicht gerade das vermeiden was man
nicht haben möchte einen großen
flächendeckenden krieg wie wir ihn
damals erlebt haben indem man präsent
ist vor ort abschreckt und auch partner
einbinden
glauben sie der präsident tram wie
versprochen gelingen die kriege in
afghanistan und im irak zu beenden also
ganz klar den auftrag gegeben an seine
berater diese kriege zu beenden aber man
kann kriege nicht einseitig beenden es
sei man kapituliert also es wird
schwierig werden für ihn die usa hier
zurück zu ziehen man kann sie kreieren
und diese regionen nicht lösen sondern
managen und ich glaube dass dann
versuchen wir zu bestmöglich diese
regionen diese krisenherde der welt zu
managen anstatt einseitig zurückzuziehen
oder zu kapitulieren
vielen herzlichen dank peter rau für
ihre einschätzung sehr gerne die kriege
in afghanistan und im irak werden wohl
weiter andauern und viele us soldaten
kehren mit psychischen problemen auf den
gefährlichen auslandseinsätzen zurück
so ist es auch einem veteranen ergangen
der heute als koch im weißen haus
arbeitet auf den ersten blick ist andrei
rasch ein durch und durch starker kern
jeden morgen macht er sage und schreibe
2222 liegestütze
doch damit stellt er nicht nur seine
arme der afghanistan veteran gedenkt der
etwa 22 kameraden die sich pro tag das
leben nehmen
auch andré selbst leidet unter einer
posttraumatischen belastungsstörung
hatte selbstmordgedanken
ich habe immer versucht so perfekt zu
sein
beim militär ging es um arbeitsmoral
fürs aufstehen fitnesstraining
gleichzeitig erlebte ich viel schlimmer
ich war am 11
september während der anschläge im
pentagon war danach im irak und
afghanistan
und dann musste ich damit klarkommen
dass einige meiner kameraden sich das
leben nahmen stellvertretend für sie und
viele andere mache ich meine liegestütze
nach außen hin gab andré immer nur den
unerschütterlichen muskelprotz im
inneren kämpfte er mit ängsten und
dämonen hier aus dem afghanistan-krieg
mitgebracht hatte irgendwann konnte er
seine psychischen probleme nicht mehr
verbergen als er die vorbildung teilen
ich hatte das schon sehr lange
einer meiner vorgesetzten ließ mich
wissen dass ich hilfe brauche ich weinte
ich wurde wütend
es kam all diese emotionen raus gehen
unserer natur liegt und dann sagte ich
worüber redest du weißt du nicht wer ich
bin
ich mache diesen job seit 23 jahren und
war immer der beste der besten und du
sagst das zu mir bis heute ist andré ein
star
er ist nicht nur für seinen bizeps
bekannt sondern auch weil er als koch im
weißen haus arbeitet hier in chicago
wird er auf einem kongress vor
us-soldaten darüber sprechen wie ihm das
kochen half mit seinen psychischen
problemen klar zu kommen
zum aufwärmen lässt an ray auch die
militärangehörigen liegestütze machen
sei nicht seine üblichen 2222 sondern
nur 22 die dafür aber ganz langsam
dann überraschte er mit einem exotischen
rezent es gibt schokoladen steak das
fleisch wird mit kakaopulver mariniert
mit seinem auftritt will andrei die
soldaten ermutigen seelische schmerzen
ernst zu nehmen und sich auch zweifeln
zu stellen etwa haben sie denn eines
auslandseinsatzes wieder haben diese
jungen soldaten über den krieg in
afghanistan nicht in frage was die
marine tut wenn es um außenpolitik
mein job ist zu tun was sie mir sagen
wenn sie mich irgendwohin schicken
ich bin nicht zum militär gegangen und
deren handlungen in frage zu stellen
sondern um sie zu unterstützen
ich habe meine persönlichen ansichten
aber wenn es um das militär geht befolge
ich befehle
denn wer auch immer mir etwas gefehlt
weiß mehr über die situation als ich ich
vertraue darauf dass sie die richtigen
entscheidungen treffen was ist die
richtige entscheidung für den einsatz
der usa in afghanistan bleiben oder
abziehen schon fast 18 jahre dauert der
krieg etwa 2.400 us soldaten kamen
bisher ums leben
[Musik]
die kosten für die usa belaufen sich auf
975 milliarden dollar
dieser tisch bleibt symbolisch frei für
jenen soldaten die nicht aus dem krieg
zurückgekommen sind
während die kämpfe in afghanistan
vorerst weitergehen wird der koch des
weißen hauses im rahmen einer rede vor
militärs dafür mehr für die selbstmord
prävention zu tun seine eigene
lebensgeschichte zeige wie wichtig es
sei aufeinander acht zu gehen ich
vergesse nie wo ich herkomme ich
vergesse nie wo ich hingehe und ich
nehme jeden mit der meine hilfe braucht
ich ermutige ich das gleiche zu tun
seit demütig bleibt demütig tut immer
euer bestes dominik die fahrer hat
zusammen mit andré in afghanistan
gekämpft dann bewundert seinen freund
für sein engagement
wir haben beide jemanden durch
selbstmord verloren dem wir nahe standen
und erst der erste mit dem ich darüber
gesprochen habe es ist ein problem aber
es gibt wege damit umzugehen und andré
macht darauf aufmerksam dass man
psychische probleme nicht verheimlichen
muss eigentlich ist es ein zeichen von
stärke hilfe zu suchen
über die frage ob der krieg in
afghanistan noch sinn macht sprechen die
freunde lieber nicht nicht in meiner
macht
ich kann mich nur darauf konzentrieren
warum ich soldat geworden wird wenn ich
diesen äußeren einflüssen erlaube
täglich meine entscheidungen zu
beeinträchtigen könnten sie meine
moralvorstellungen aufzählen psychische
probleme von soldaten früher zu erkennen
und zu behandeln
dafür kämpft andreas todt präsident
trump aus seiner sicht genug
[Musik]
ich denke die regierung versucht schon
zu tun was sie kann
aber es gibt immer raum für
verbesserungen doch das kostet natürlich
zeit personal und geld persönlich hat er
das seinem chef präsident trump noch
nicht gesagt er äußere nur seine meinung
wenn er danach gefragt werde sagt der
koch vom weißen haus
präsident trampert sein land und die
rolle amerikas auf der weltbühne
verändert er hat die wirtschaft
angekurbelt und vier in weißen
amerikaner der unteren mittelschicht
ihren stolz zurückgegeben
in der außenpolitik hat trump freunde
wie feinde immer wieder überrascht bald
wird sich zeigen ob er mit dieser
strategie das weiße haus verteidigen
kann
der unberechenbare präsident